i'll put the spoiler warning up for our
viewers right now because i just want to
know
everything and anything about your
death scene and maybe specifically is
there anything about
the makeup effects and visual effects
necessary to pull that off that just
really wowed you
well that was the most strange thing no
one has asked me that
but because they you know my face
is supposed to be like turn around they
literally put
my boobs in the back and my ass
in the front like they just changed my
body
and then they put this prosthetic
with the thing and i was in the
prosthetic for like
like since 7 a.m and i started shooting
that
like around 1 and it was very
uncomfortable and it was hitting right
here
so it was it was a very that was my most
uncomfortable my least favorite day
because it was it was like carrying this
thing and it was so weird because it was
hitting something
here and it was making me emotional i
don't know why
so i just started crying like i just
in the middle of the day and then they
they gave me some cbd gummies and then i
was fine
for what it's worth it looked incredible